[Music]
jordan's with us in little rock arkansas
hi jordan how are you
hi dave i'm doing great how are you
better than i deserve what's up
uh so i just went through your financial
peace
university and the legacy journey
and it was awesome great
and uh my question for you is kind of
following in your footsteps
how do you become a billionaire
a billionaire
yes sir i've heard you say that's one of
your goals and
i know you said like mutual funds won't
get you there and it's
kind of capped at like five million or
something like that so no it's not
it's not capped at that but what i said
was was that we've just done this book
baby steps millionaires and the
difference in a million and a billion is
a billion is a thousand million so
you know you can become a millionaire
everybody can uh without a doubt using
your 401k and funding it generously like
following the baby steps and then
getting your house paid off and that's
the typical way people become
millionaires
the first one to five million is what i
was saying on that it doesn't cap at
that but um
there's only so much though that you can
put into a 401k
and
so there's only so much you're going to
have in a 401k so you're not going to
get to
a 100 million dollars in your 401k it's
not it's not mathematically possible so
uh and that would only be a tenth of a
billion
so
typically now i don't i'm not an expert
on billionaires i am on millionaires uh
i have studied them and i've looked at
the numbers a lot uh i'll tell you what
i generally see
uh all the forbes 400 is now
billionaires there's no nobody no one in
the force 400 that's not at least worth
a billion at least one billion
um and uh bezos is hundreds of billions
i mean it's crazy so
but uh the vast majority uh 70 of the
forbes 400 the wealthiest people in
america
are uh first generation meaning they
earned it from nothing
and so they didn't inherit it that's
good news so that means a lot of you got
a shot at it
um
the billionaires that i have personally
met and i've probably met now
in person uh
25 or 30 and i've you know studied and
read about a lot of the others the vast
majority of them made their money in
a business
they created a thing they created a
thing okay so you look at michael dell
okay you look at uh truett kathy or bill
gates you look at bill gates you look at
uh you know
oprah winfrey these are business people
that created a business that became very
very large and so the vast majority of
my wealth beyond
the first 10 million net worth that i
made has been from the business ramsey
solutions
gotcha so is that something where it's
like you need to take a company public
kind of thing
could or don't have to
uh chick-fil-a's not public ramsey
solutions is not public
uh hobby lobby is not public and david
green would be on that list
do you kind of still hold the same
principles with like
financing businesses like that i don't
finance anything no we're starting
something like there's no there's no
there's no indication debt caused them
to become a billionaire
uh but what it did it was some kind of a
they were adding value to the
marketplace they're adding value to the
community and people paid them for it so
they they you know bill gates uh you
know most famous example kim comes up
with a personal computer right apple you
know uh uh is not attributed to a
singular person but
where you're adding value you're the a
good or a service that you are bringing
is
uh extremely valuable um elon musk you
know is um
uh adding value uh with the tesla and
spacex and so on and
uh so these people and a lot of them are
people you might not be household names
like we're mentioning those are all
multi billionaires but the first 1
to 10 billion even
uh
an unusual number of them did it with a
business i can't i don't have actual
facts on it in terms of i can show you
percentages or i've broken it down or
i've done detailed research but that's
just anecdotally looking at it and
saying okay who's on that list
where'd their money come from and you
just kind of do it that way and uh it's
kind of a common sense approach to the
repeat
to
the first round of what could become
detailed research but i doubt i'll do
detailed research on a billionaire
where did the narrative
come that
if you were wealthy it's because you did
nothing and someone gave it to you
because it the the data in your book
says that's false it's just simply
inaccurate and then i had never even
thought about the billionaires
that i'm sure there's saudi princes and
whatever and it but
these folks like
man talk about right place the right
time the world shuts down and i got this
little company called amazon that
deliver stuff to your door yeah you know
what i mean yeah like they created
something of value yep and
and that's where the money comes from
you know it's
someone got helped someone got served
someone got entertained yeah and that's
where the money comes from but this
narrative is that well the narrative is
marxism i mean you cannot support
communism as a as an economic
methodology
uh
unless you first have to lay the
groundwork and say
uh
that
all of the wealth the that the
aristocracy that has the wealth are evil
and so it must be taken away from them
you have to vilify you got to be
somebody back and the problem is is in
america that the people that they're
vilifying are successful people and the
problem is they're successful helping
other people they're helping other
people and so the narrative won't hold
water in america because people are
walking around going no i know that guy
he's not i know that gal
they're not i don't hate oprah you know
i'm sorry you know you can't it's not
it's not legal to hate oprah you know
it's not
i mean you can't you can't you know i'm
not
you can't go okay kill all the rich
people you know like a uh you know the
russian revolution right and uh which
was brought on by marxism i'm brought on
by communism so you it whether it's that
level of violence or not you can't in
order to say
that that
life is unfair and so we have to have
anarchy we have to change the whole
system of economics two to one where
everyone is equal right okay uh the only
way that that works is you have to first
vilify
the ones that have the money those who
are above the the bell curve are evil
yeah that's how they got and you know if
they if they were uh russian aristocrats
in 1901
you could go back and probably prove
that they were
inbred evil and had no reason for having
the money the money was handed to them
and they brought provided no value to
the community so it was a lot easier to
get mad at them kill them all right and
karl marx you know steps up right and so
that's uh uh
that but but the problem or him jeff
bezos drops boxes off at my house well
he doesn't i know he has it has somebody
do it for him but yeah but but i mean he
provides me with the surface whether you
like him or not you know a lot of people
use what he has yeah and whether you
like bill gates or not or whether you
like you know uh
the whole microsoft movement versus the
apple movement or whatever all that
doesn't matter it doesn't matter bottom
line is is the personal computer has
changed the world right
you and i have things sitting on my desk
here that filled a room
uh just a generation ago the the brain
power and so and those men the michael
dales and the women are involved in
these things in silicon valley
and they brought value right now are
there robber barons out there yeah of
course
everywhere though but by and large
they're not the norm right the norm and
so you have to say
you have to vilify success and it just
is it's they're having trouble doing
that in america because the data is
against them that's yeah the data's so
clear it's very clear yeah and so you go
okay
uh you know
how can you make it without some
cheese's chicken i mean you gotta have
chick-fil-a right so um
it's like a it's a you know if you don't
have some ever so often you're just not
okay so it's uh they serve a lot of
people with the fastest service at a
drive-through anywhere right and
high-quality hot food and they're kind
and wonderful teenagers working there
that no manners and wear a belt and it's
pretty amazing
and um you know so it's you know
how you gonna vilify that right uh well
you have to
if you want to tear it down
first have to make it bad if you want to
tear it down
and that
and the problem is it's a lie it's not
true it's not true and so it won't hold
water it's not it doesn't work here so
you wealth inequality people
sorry you're going to take your
communism to a different continent it's
not going to work here